um all right hi everyone welcome back to
cs330 um and today we'll be talking
about hierarchy coloring personal
learning and skill discovery
uh let's see how this works
all right so um the plan for the lecture
is the following first we'll discuss why
we should uh work on things such as
hierarchical reinforcement and skill
discovery
then we will
talk a little bit about some information
theoretic concepts that
will come in handy when discussing
different approaches and some of these
concepts you might be already familiar
with such as scale divergence or entropy
but we'll go over them anyway just to
make sure that we're all on the same
page
then we'll discuss skill discovery
algorithms
and once we kind of learn how how we can
discover skills we'll also try to learn
how we can use them and different
options that we should consider there
and then
at the end we'll also talk about
hierarchical reinforcement learning
algorithms
all right
so let's start with
discussing why skill discovery is
something that is that is important
and
so far in the course we've been mostly
in a scenario where the task was
something that was given to us and then
we're trying to find a policy or
come up with an algorithm that will be
able to to solve for that specific task
right and
while this is a useful setting it
doesn't really cover everything that
that we might want our agents to do
so in particular when you consider how
we learn it's not necessarily that we
always get a goal or some kind of task
that is given to us by somebody else and
that we are trying to accomplish we're
also really good at coming up with our
own goals and our own
skills that we might want to practice
so we want to change the the question
that we're considering and we would want
our agents to also be able to discover
interesting behaviors without any
supervision
so in particular i wanted to show you
this this little video of a baby left
completely unattended in the room and
you can see that uh you know the baby is
not given any specific goals
but it's still pretty good at coming up
with with the goals to practice and
through its own curiosity it's not only
coming up with them but then it's also
trying to practice them and and trying
to get better at all of them so we want
to get to a situation where we can leave
a robot unattended in the room
and that robot will come up with
anything that there is to do in that
room that is interesting and then we
come back and the robot is capable of
doing many different skills
right there's also a slightly different
motivation
which is um based off on some of the
research
that comes more from neuroscience and
biology
um and in this particular uh paper that
i'm citing here um researchers were
doing a study on frogs
and um
they were trying to discover or trying
to research what kind of how how does
the frog move and how does the spinal
cord of the frog
modulate all different behaviors
and um what they what they found out is
that there's a very small number of core
skills that the frog knows about
and then the whole variety of motions
that the frog can do comes from spinal
cord just modulating these different
core level skills
right so there's a small number of core
skills and these give rise to a large
variety of behaviors
there's also a similar research in that
vein that was done on human subjects
where the researchers were asking humans
to grasp a large variety of objects and
then they would record the hand
positions of the humans and
try to do some analysis on the data
so they collected this big data set with
many different humans grasping many
different objects
and then they perform principal
component analysis in the dataset and
they and they notice that with just a
few top principle components they can
explain a huge majority of the data
so that also seems to point to something
similar where we have a small number of
core skills or call behaviors that can
then give rise to a large variety of of
of things of skills
so one other motivation for skill
discovery is that maybe if we leave
robots on a tendon and allow them to
discover the skills themselves rather
than us defining what they should be
maybe they will be able to come up with
these core skills that then would allow
us to generate all kinds of things
all right there's also a much more
practical motivation for skill discovery
or for skill discovery algorithms and
this is that
you know so far we talked a lot about
multi-task reinforcement learning or
meta reinforcement learning and we
always assume that we have a
bag of tasks that we can pre-train on
right and
once you start implementing these things
you very quickly realize that coming up
with the task itself themselves is
really tricky
um
and uh there are many different
considerations that that
you have to think about while you do
this
and very often it's just uh one of the
limiting factors is that we just
we are having trouble with coming up
with big enough set of tasks
and
this might seem a little
counterintuitive so i thought maybe we
can do a short exercise
um so i'll ask you to write in the chat
you also feel free to raise your hand if
you have any questions um i would like
you to write down some write down some
task ideas for a tabletop manipulation
scenario and just to make it a little
bit more specific it's a tabletop
manipulation scenario where we have a
robot with a single arm
that is in front of a table
and it can be given any objects right so
can you can you just write down any task
that comes to mind and just write as
many as you can think of
grab something okay
pick up stacking object picking up the
spoon okay we got three pickups
push down objects from the table pour
milk into a cup move the arm dismantle
the table whoa that's a complicated one
read the paper okay that would be
interesting
move to a specific location pet a dog
rotate arm
salt chess
okay
throw
do the harmless again that's a that's a
perfect one
just end up using support i'm not sure
what that what do you mean by that
exactly
um
oh i guess it's like a it's a humanoid
robot that needs to stand up using some
kind of support
take a port of table distance oh i see
okay great
roll an object all right
this is actually like a lot of really
good ideas and my i might use some of
these so thanks a lot these are great
um
all right so um
uh i think one thing to consider here is
that so we have a lot of
things that are kind of close to each
other like picking objects or grabbing
objects
um but we have also a lot of things that
are at very different levels of
difficulty right we had i think someone
wrote to uh dismantle this or assemble a
table
right so and the difficulty of that task
compared to and just grasping something
is very very different
right so when we come up with the with
the all the different tasks that we want
the robot to do
we also need to keep in mind the the
practical algorithms that will try to
learn these tasks so we we usually want
to come up with a task that are feasible
with our current url algorithms that are
at similar that are of the similar
levels of difficulty so that we can
train all of them at the same time and
we also want to make them such that they
share a lot of similar structures so
that if you train a lot of them they can
kind of benefit from all the other tasks
all right so you're really good at this
um
i just wanted to mention that when we
were going through the exercise when we
were developing the benchmark meta world
that was really really painful
and it was really tricky to come up with
this many tasks and uh do this such that
uh each one of these tasks is feasible
by a single test reinforcement
algorithms so
um especially when you work on these
projects
use that creativity that you just that
you just displayed and come up with as
many tasks as you as you can and i think
if you do this that the algorithms will
become much better too
all right so we talked a little bit
about why skill discovery might be
useful so why hierarchical reinforcement
learning
um so so far when we were talking about
reinforcement algorithms we're
considering um every single task to be
at the same level of abstraction
so for example if we're controlling the
robot at a specific frequency we'll be
sending
actions at that frequency
but we might want to ask the robot to do
tests at very different level of
abstractions right we can for example we
can
tell the robot to go bake a cheesecake
but we can also be much more specific
than that and say well first you need to
buy ingredients and we want to treat
these two a little bit differently
also the first step to do that would be
to go to the store or to walk to the
door take a step or contract a specific
muscle
and we would want our algorithms to be
able to reason on all these levels of
abstractions such that the lower levels
can inform the higher levels and we
don't necessarily want to plan for
baking a cheesecake by planning every
single muscle contraction we want to do
it at much higher level
and these are these are the things that
hierarchical reinforcement learning
algorithms would allow us to do
in addition to this it can be very
useful with exploration
so
when we are considering some tasks that
can be much more long-term tasks
for example block stacking we don't
necessarily plan in terms of contracting
our muscles or
how are we going to move our finger and
so on but we're
thinking in much higher level of
abstraction we were just thinking about
the objects and where the objects should
go and this allows us to do this
planning much more efficiently and allow
us for better exploration
so we'll also use hierarchical real
algorithms too to help us with that
all right great so this is a little bit
of a motivation um are there any
questions at this point
please raise your hand if there are any
questions or just speak up
all right it's not then
um there's a question in the chat
uh does the human imposed hierarchy
um
can can the human impose hierarchy
potentially be suboptimal
yeah definitely i think so
um
so we we will also learn about um
algorithms that try to learn the how to
do the hierarchy itself so what are the
low-level skills that they should it
should learn and the high-level skills
that they should learn together with so
it will be kind of an end-to-end process
that will learn
both levels
there is still a little bit of human
imposed hierarchy or human
injected knowledge about you know this
being just
two levels of hierarchy as opposed to
many more or maybe the tasks shouldn't
have shouldn't have been solved in a
hierarchical fashion in the first place
and i think this is a really interesting
question as to you know how much is this
constraining our algorithms as opposed
to helping them
all right so um let's jump into some
information throughout the concept so
there will be a little bit of theory but
it should be relatively straightforward
and for some of you this might not be
new and you might have heard about this
before but we'll go over this really
quickly
all right so first we'll talk about
entropy
and in order to introduce that that
concept we first need to talk about the
distribution
so hopefully we are all familiar with
uh with distributions um and here we'll
be plotting a distribution of a
one-dimensional variable x
so on the x-axis
uh
the x-axis we have our different values
that the random variable can take and
then the y-axis we have the probability
of the random variable taking that value
so then we can observe what kind of
values the random variable takes and
then we can fit a distribution that has
to sum up to one
that that corresponds to these events so
for example a gaussian in this case
right so this is what the probability
distribution is
now
we'll refer to entropy as this script h
and it's an entropy of a particular
distribution
and mathematically it's defined as
following
it's a negative log probability log p of
x
under the expectation of
right so so what does that mean so let's
try to think about the terms that we
have here
so
that expectation here means that if we
sample from our distribution from our p
of x so we'll just sample according to
this distribution
the um
if the entropy
is very high
then for the samples we sample
the log p of x should be quite low
right so basically if we want to
maximize the entropy that means we need
to minimize this this negative term here
so for the samples that we sampled from
our distribution the probability mass
shouldn't be that big should be as low
as possible so what does that mean in
practice
so in practice that means that if i
sample something that means that
that sample doesn't carry a lot of
probability distribution so basically
it measures how broad our distribution
is if our distribution is much broader
than something as big as this gaussian
in the in the picture for example
something that
let's say looks like
this
um
that means that we will have a lot of
samples that we are likely to sample for
example a sample here or a sample there
that don't have as much probability mass
as they would have had if we sample
something from a distribution that is
much more peaky
right so if i sample something from a
gaussian like this that means that the
uh the the probability that i so so i'm
very likely to get a sample that is
close to that peak and that sample will
carry a lot of probability mass right
here
right so basically entropy is a measure
of how random our distribution is or how
much randomness there was in that random
variable
the other way to to think about this is
to think about it a little bit
counterintuitively so um
count as our uh an entropy will tell us
um
how easily can you guess
what the sample will be
right so let me give you a little bit
better example here um so let's consider
a bernoulli random variable so if we're
just doing a coin flip
and here on the x-axis we'll be plotting
the parameter of that bernoulli random
variable so 0.5 means that heads and
tails are equally likely
and on the y-axis we are plotting the
entropy itself
and here we can see that the entropy is
the highest for the value 0.5
so what that means is that it's
extremely hard for us to guess uh
whether the outcome of that random event
will be tails or heads
if uh
if the uh
the the parameter of the bernoulli
probability distribution would be 0.5
however if that probability distribution
uh that that parameter the probability
of getting tails for instance is equal
1.1.0
that means that entropy is very low i
don't even have to perform the
experiments to know uh what i will get
right from the parameter itself i can
basically easily predict what's going to
happen
so it measures a little bit how much
randomness there is in that random
variable
all right
so this is a little bit about the
entropy let's talk about kl divergence
um so you've heard a little bit about kl
divergence and we usually have been
introducing it as a distance between two
distributions
right so let's define it mathematically
so kl divergence is dkl between two
distributions q and p
it's another symmetric measure that is
defined defined like this
it's an expectation under one of these
distributions under under distribution q
a block of the ratio between the two
distributions
log of the ratio between q of x and p of
x
now because these are logarithms we can
um
uh we can change it to to look like this
so it's the difference between these two
expectations
and then we can change it a little bit
further and say that this is this
negative expectation of the log p of x
minus the entropy of q of x
right so here i just use the definition
that we just introduced definition of
the entropy uh
that so i transformed this term and put
the minus in front of it so that it's an
entropy
all right so since this is a distance
let's first think about uh the simplest
case where q and p are equal to each
other and whether the distance would be
zero
and we can easily see for example from
this part of the equation here that this
would be the case so
if
p was equal to q
or q is equal to p then
that expectation would be equal exactly
to this expectation and then they will
cancel each other out this would be
equal to zero
right so let's take a look at the final
formula that we got here and let's try
to understand it a little bit better
and in order to understand this
we'll first plot some probability
distribution p of x
and this is let's say some complex
probability distribution that looks like
this
right and now what we'll try to do is
we'll try to find a probability
distribution q
that is a gaussian we'll try to find the
parameters of this gaussian such that
the kl divergence between q and p is as
small as possible so we're trying to
find the q that minimizes
that
that kl divergence that is defined here
all right
so because we're trying to minimize this
that means that we have to maximize the
negative so we're first maximizing this
term right here
so let's just focus on that term
and for this term in order to maximize
it we need to come up with a
distribution q
that is extremely
peaky here
so that if you sample from the
distribution so if we sample from our
queue this is the expectation under q
the log probability
of p of x would be as high as possible
so there's as much probability mass as
possible
so this basically corresponds to a
distribution that is very very narrow
and then just looking and it looks for a
mode in the distribution p of x right
it's a mode seeking behavior because if
we put any probability mass for uh the
distribution q of x anywhere else then
the log probability distribution for
that sample would be much smaller than
it would have been for the mode
all right so this is the first term so
it's a mode seeking behavior that
produces an extremely narrow
distribution
and then we have the second term which
is the entropy of our q of x
and we already learned a little bit
about the entropy so we are trying to
make this entropy as big as possible so
that the negative would be as small as
possible
and that entropy will try to make the
distribution wider
so we just talked about how entropy
measures how broad the distribution is
so that entropy if we try to make it as
big as possible it will transform our
mode seeking distribution into something
that is a little bit wider
and here from this picture you can see
kind of the behavior that you will get
if you are trying to minimize the kld
version scale divergence of this form
with respect to q so it will you'll try
to find the mode of the distribution and
then you'll try to blow it up a little
bit so that it covers as much
probability mass of p of x as possible
all right so this is a bit about kl
divergence so let's introduce the the
last term that uh you might find useful
in today's lecture which is mutual
information
so mutual information will depict will
denote of this
script i
and is between two random variables
let's say x and y
and mathematically it's defined as
following it's a kl divergence between
the joint distribution and the product
of the marginals
so we can write it out fully like this
but instead of analyzing it in this form
i'll just i'll just try to give you two
examples of what mutual information is
and then we'll change the formula a
little bit to get more intuition of
how we can think about mutual
information
so here we have two random variables
x and y
and we are plotting
different samples from from these
distributions
and now
what mutual information is trying to
measure is how much is x dependent on y
and vice versa so if you knew about x
how much would you know about y
so in this um in this plot right here
what we can say is that if we knew what
what value of x we had then we can
fairly confidently predict what y we are
going to get the dependence between x
and y is very high
so this is an example of a high mutual
information where x and i are x and y
are dependent on each other
here in the bottom plot
the the plot is all looks a little bit
differently but regardless of what x
what what value of x the random variable
takes y is not really changing so even
if you knew about x that wouldn't really
help you in guessing what y is going to
be
so in this case x and y are independent
and therefore there's low mutual
information between between these two
random variables
all right so let's change that that
formula that we got right here to
something that looks a little bit closer
to what we've seen before
and uh
in particular this is actually a
somewhat uh symmetric measure and it
tells you the mutual information is
equal to the entropy of the first
variable minus the entropy of the
conditional distribution of p of x given
y
all right
so what what does that mean so we know
intuitively that mutual information
measures the dependency between these
two variables
so let's try to analyze this so mutual
information will be high
if that term is high
so that means that the entropy of p of x
is really high so you can't really tell
what x you're going to get if you sample
from those distributions really it's
it's very random distribution it's very
wide
so x on itself has high entropy
but then for the mutual information to
be high this term needs to be very low
all right so that means that the entropy
of p of x given y needs to be very low
so
if i just
ask you to predict what x is going to be
you will have no idea it would be very
very hard but if i told you what y
um you get to experience well what y is
then you would be able to very conflict
confidently tell me what x is going to
be there's a high dependence between y
and x so x by itself is very random but
as soon as you know about y you know
what the x will be
all right so let's go for a little
exercise to see whether this makes sense
so i'll give you an example of two
random variables x and y and i'll ask
you whether they have high mutual
information or low initial information
so in the chat you can just write high
or low
all right so here we go we have one
random variable that says
it will rain tomorrow it rains tomorrow
and then another random variable that
says streets are wet tomorrow
so it's a time usual information yeah
okay hi hi hi
great yes this is these are very
dependent random variables
and basically you can say that the the
entropy of whether it's going to rain
tomorrow or not is actually fairly high
we have no idea whether whether it's
going to rain or not
um i guess maybe in the bay area it's a
little different but still
but if we knew that streets are wet
tomorrow will be very it will be very
easy for us to tell whether it's going
to rain or not
all right let's go for another example
so access still it rains tomorrow and
why is we find life on mars tomorrow
is it high or low mutual information
right this is fairly straightforward
yeah it's low mutual information because
um
even though the entropy of p of x is
still fairly high we can't really tell
whether it's going to rain tomorrow or
not uh
the the additional information that
we're getting about why that we find
live on mars tomorrow is not really
going to help us guess whether it's
going to rain tomorrow or not
all right great
um so this is a little bit more abstract
so i'll give you a particular example of
mutual information that is actually used
in reinforcement learning
and this is called empowerment
and the mutu the the empowerment is
mutual information between the next
state and the current action
so does anybody have any idea why this
is called empowerment
please just speak up or you can write in
a chat or raise your hand
whatever works for you
great the new ideas
the current action basically determines
next state the impact of the action yes
exactly right so that means that the
empowerment would be very high
if your actions have a lot of control
over the state that you're going to
observe next
so if your actions are very powerful if
they have a lot of influence on the next
state that means that you're a highly
empowered individual
all right great and we a lot of people
use that measure as something to
optimize for or something to to measure
how
capable the agents are
all right so we did a little review of
some information throughout the concepts
are there any questions at this point
all right
okay
so let's talk about some skill discovery
algorithms
um so
um
in one thing that we would want to do in
skill discovery is to find algorithms
that don't necessarily solve one
particular task but algorithms that can
solve many many different tasks and they
can come up with the tasks
themselves
so one algorithm that goes towards this
direction that we already talked about
is a soft q learning
algorithm
and in sub-q learning
the setting we're considering was still
where
we had a task that was given to us for
example a dog that has to come to the
owner but its behavior is a little more
stochastic it doesn't just go in a
straight line but it's uh it's a little
more stochastic than that
in particular the objective that the
agent was optimizing to look like this
and here we have the additional entropy
term that we just discussed
and then we had value and q functions as
we described and then we had a standard
q learning algorithm and we made some
modifications to it
resulting in a soft q learning algorithm
that allowed us to be a little bit less
committed that
a standard url algorithm would
and then we looked at some of the
results here that allowed us to not be
as committed to a single solution as you
are for example in this case where our
policy is just picking the mode of our q
function and always trying to do those
actions and instead we'll put a little
bit of probability mass for our policy
even for the actions that are not
perfectly optimal all right so this is
something that goes a little bit in the
direction we want in that it can do more
things than just one particular test
because at least it can do it in many
different ways
right but this is not exactly what we
need
this is still a little bit different so
what we would need that would be a
policy
that would have a form
that would look something like that so
it would be a policy pi of a given s as
we usually do
but it will be conditioned on one
additional random variable and that
random variable will depict as well the
node is task index or some kind of skill
index
so we want the agent to do different
things depending on the value of z
and that z could be just an integer so
for instance if we have an agent that is
um
performing different tasks in in this
little grid that the agent starts right
here in the middle of it then with
different z's a different z-score would
with differences we would want the agent
to go toward two different places or to
visit different part of the state space
so for example if our z is equal to zero
maybe the agent would move up
z is equal to one it will move to the
right
if it's equal to two then the agent
would explore this uh
bottom right corner
three would be a different trajectory
for a different trajectory and five
would be a different trajectory too
right so we want the agent that will
have a that we want a policy such that
with different task indices that policy
will do completely different things
and we can't really use just max
entropyrl to learn something like this
because first of all action entropy is
not the same as state entropy so we can
have an agent that can act uh very
differently in so in a specific state it
can make take very different actions but
that doesn't necessarily mean that it
will land in different states it can
land in very similar states
and in addition to this our max entropy
policies so these soft learning policies
um are stochastic but they're not
controllable so we can't very easily
pick what kind of solution we want
versus here we would want to have a full
control through our z variable to tell
the agent what kind of skill what kind
of test we wanted to perform
all right so intuitively what we would
want
is something that results in low
diversity for a fixed c so if i tell the
agent what i what kind of task index i
want we want the agent to know what to
do
but then across about high diversity
across different z's so if i didn't tell
what z i i want we want the agent that
can visit any part of the state space
all right so the intuition is that
different skills should visit different
states-based regions
so let's try to come up with an
algorithm that could do something like
that
so in order to do this we in order to
learn this policy we would need to learn
some kind of reward function that is
fully automated
so that reward function
will be in addition to being conditioned
on state it will be also conditioned on
the skill itself right so given what
skill you're doing that the reward
function will be a little bit different
but we want it to be automated we don't
really want to come up with the three
word function for every single task that
we have uh that we hand engineered but
we want the agent to discover disease
itself and then have the automated
reward function for that specific
right and then
the the objective of the agent would be
to just maximize the reward that
automated reward that we haven't come up
with yet
across all the
differences right
so here's one idea how we can do this
what we can propose for the reward
function
so we'll reward the states that are
unlikely for other zs
so so what does that mean exactly
so if our reward
is rewarding every state that um
that the current z can visit then none
of the other z scan and that would mean
that we are covering the state space
fairly well and that skill is fairly
distinct from all the other skills
right so if for example our z was equal
to two uh let's say we would want the
agent to discover this part of the state
space and this is a different part of
the state space that the agent would
have discovered if we give had we given
it any other z any different z so either
this one or that one or so on
all right so
that idea at least on the surface kind
of makes sense so how could we how could
we formalize it a little bit more
right so we want to reward the states
that are unlikely for others ease
so here's one proposal that we can do
we can learn a classifier that given a
state
tells us what z could have resulted in
us visiting that state
right so we can easily train a
classifier like this that classifier can
be trained using supervised learning and
it will be just looking at the states
but at the states that a particular
skill has visited and we'll try to
regress towards that skill
and then we can have the reward function
that tries to help this classifier as
much as possible
so it tries to make the skills uh a
little bit more diverse such as does
this classifier have a very easy job
right so let's go through a little
example so that um it makes a little
more sense
so um in the standard url setting we'll
have the policy that produces actions in
the environment and then gets a state as
an input and keeps going
here we'll have
an additional input which is the the
skill that we're currently doing
but we'll also have this discriminator
this classifier that given a state would
will try to tell us what z could have
accomplished that state could have ended
up in that state
and these two will be interacting with
each other
right so in practice it it would work
like this
we would start with sampling two
different z's and giving it to our
policy
and we'll get two different trajectories
so let's say the trajectory in green is
was produced for z equals zero and the
trajectory in blue was produced for z
equal one and they're very close to each
other but they're slightly different
so now in the next step we'll try to
learn a classifier that tries to learn
the decision boundary between these two
trajectories
so it's trying to do the best job it can
these trajectories are fairly entangled
so it's a little tricky but it's trying
to separate the green trajectory from
the blue trajectory and let's say it
came up with a decision boundary that
looks like this
well that's not really perfect but it's
the best job it could do
right so now we have a policy that the
given that classifier is now this this
discriminator is now trying to help it
right it's trying to make the next
iteration for a little bit easier so
given the decision boundary
it will try to produce the trajectories
in the next generation
that will make the current classifier a
little bit better because we are
rewarding our policy or maximizing uh
that
the likelihood of that classifier
right so it will produce two
trajectories that are
more different
and then we'll do another iteration of
the classifier so the classifier will
learn a little bit better decision
boundary
and then we'll continue doing so so then
our policy will try to help the
classifier again and we'll produce
trajectories that are even different and
then we'll get better decision boundary
and so on
all right so overall we see that there's
this uh two player game where both
players are
going to towards the same goal
where the discriminator is trying to the
best job possible in trying to classify
uh which skills would or which skills
would produce certain states
and then
the policy is trying to make the
classifier's job as easy as possible
so does that make sense are there any
questions in the spine
all right
okay so let's look at some examples of
an algorithm that does exactly this and
let's try to see what kind of
task so first the outfirst
trades algorithm on the cheetah task
where we have a cheetah that usually the
task of the cheetah is to run forward as
fast as possible but here the only
reward that is optimizing is trying to
help that classifier
so it's trying to produce skills that
are as diverse as possible so that the
classifier has very easy job
and here are some examples of the skills
it came up with so one of them is
cheetah running forward and then we have
some other skills such as cheetah doing
backflips or cheater running backwards
here's also a different environment
using exactly the same algorithm where
we have the ant that is trying to learn
a whole bunch of different behaviors by
optimizing this diversity objective
and here we have a particular example of
a mountain car
where one of the solutions that is just
uh just comes out from this diversity
objective is actually to just solve the
task and this is the one the at the very
top
all right so we discuss a little bit the
the intuition behind this why we would
want to come up with a classifier and so
on but we also introduced this concept
of mutual information
so
let's try to see if there's some
connection between the algorithm that we
just developed and the concept of mutual
information
so this is so far here what we've
written here is everything that we
discussed so far and let's consider a
specific mutual information which is the
mutual information between our
skill index or task index and the
current state
using the definition of mutual
information that we talked about it
would it would
look like something like this
and now the first term
will be maximized if we are just using a
maximum uniform prior over our skills so
basically if we want to maximize the
entropy over z that means that we need
to be able to sample every skill with
the same probability
so
if our z is just a categorical random
variable it should be distributed
uniformly such that every skill has a
chance to go
and then the second term here
is minimized by maximizing our log
probability of p of z given s
right so this is by maximizing our
classifier by trying to help our
classifier as much as possible
right so that basically says that given
the the state i should be able to tell
what skill produced that state
our policy is trying to uh to minimize
this term by maximizing uh that log
probability of the classifier
all right so this is a skill discovery
algorithm that was trying to discover
skills that are as diverse as possible
and they might not be very useful but at
least they try to cover as much of the
state space as possible are there any
questions at this point
there's a question in the chat that's
asking is there an optimal number of z
that covers the entire state space while
not overlapping between different z
right so the overlapping part is
hopefully taken care of by the
um by the algorithm itself so regardless
of what the number of these is the
algorithm will try to as long as you
sample them uniformly the algorithm will
try to
cover
uh or make sure that they don't overlap
with each other
now
is there optimal number of z's uh to
cover the entire state space um i think
this is a very
tricky question and we don't really have
an answer to this
um so
it would
i think it would we would need to have
some kind of way of describing a state
space in a way
that we can discuss its coverage
um
and overall i don't think we have an
answer to this so in practice what we
would do is we would set
z to be a categorical random variable
that can take values from you know from
one to a big number and then we'll see
what kind of skill it produces but i
don't think there is any or i haven't
seen any research that has been done on
what kind of uh how big the z should be
to cover the state space i think this is
a
very good question and but very tricky
to answer
all right
thanks
all right so um
now let's talk a little bit about how we
can use these discovered skills
right
so
so far we discussed that how we can
learn a policy
that uh given different z values that
could be just integers will produce
different behaviors
but we don't want to just learn a
diverse set of skills we want to learn
them such that we can then later use
them to do some kind of task
right so for example we might want to
learn some kind of way of using them
such that we can perform a navigation
task where we have that and that has to
navigate to different points
right so one question is
how can we
use the learn skills to accomplish a new
task that is given to us at test time
are there any ideas here
please raise your hand or write in the
chat
so just to just to repeat the question
we have a low-level policy that can do
different things dependent on on the
value of z
right so for differences it will do very
different things
um
now we want to find the policy that is
able to reuse these skills to do a
particular task
all right you can optimize the z
sequence right yeah okay so we can learn
another policy on top of it that
operates on on z's right so now instead
of the standard actions being our
actions a that policy will be optimizing
for the perfect z sequence
um to accomplish a new task
right and this is actually what's done
in the paper that um
that uh we're just discussing which is
called diversity zone you need it's um
it was written by ben eisenbach and at
all
and
they try to then repurpose the skills
that they already learned to learn tasks
that are um that are kind of more useful
and they they show results uh showing
quite quite convincingly that you can
learn a policy a high-level policy that
operates on disease and it can find how
what's the best way to use these skills
to accomplish a particular task
all right so this seems like a
good idea this could work
but
can we do better than this
and
when we think about how we could do
better
let's try to think a little bit what are
the problems with the solution
so one problem that
we can see is that the skills that the
algorithm comes up with might not be
particularly useful so it might be just
an and you know doing kind of random
motions random water babbling but us as
long as that as that behavior is
different than the other behavior it
will still be perfectly acceptable but
that won't be really useful for
something that we might want the end to
do a little bit later
and then in addition to this
if you think about learning an
additional policy that operates on these
latent variable z's
on this task indices z
it's
it's not very used it's not very easy to
use these learning skills right we need
to run another reinforcement learning
algorithm that will learn that policy
and that will take many samples and the
rel is tricky in general so it's not
that you can just
very quickly use these skills straight
away and kind of be done with a new task
right so we'll start with focusing on
the first question right here
that skills might not be particularly
useful and try to think of
ways how we can make them more useful
and then we can uh see how that results
in a partial answer to the second
question as well
right so um
here's a question to you
um what do you think makes a useful
skill
so right now we're just coming up with
very diverse skills how can we
how can we constrain this a little bit
more and say that skills have to be
useful
and please remember that we don't have
access to any tasks right we're doing
this uh completely unsupervised where
the the agent has to discover the skills
themselves
are there any ideas what makes a useful
skill
please write in a chat or
um raise your hand
and this is actually a very tricky
question so
you know don't feel bad if you um
there's nothing that comes to mind
but i'll give you another 30 seconds or
so
state action spaces are different from
other skills
all right yes so state action spaces are
different from other skills this is
similar to the objective that we had
before where
it's optimizing for diversity of skills
right so as long as they're diverse they
should be useful
um that's a very good objective and you
know it results in a useful algorithm
that we just saw uh but can we do a
little bit better can we make the skills
more useful they can be combined to
something okay that's a really good idea
maybe the skill is performed over and
over during the optimization process
skills that utilizes different parts of
motions
okay yeah i think these are some good
ideas here
um great so
um let me try to
convince you to one particular property
uh that would help us to make skills a
little bit more useful
and i want to show you two examples
of things that are not necessarily very
useful so we have an ant that is doing
kind of random motions and it's not
really clear what's going to happen and
then we have this uh
this uh this kid that is playing with
jenga and also the consequences are kind
of catastrophic but more importantly
it's kind of very tricky to predict
what's going to happen
and then here are some examples of
skills that are very useful right so in
at the bottom we can see the ants that
is just running forward as fast as
possible
and up top we can see uh this cartoon
character juggling really well
right so um i'll make an assumption that
what makes a useful skill
is uh how hard are how how easy it is to
predict the consequences of performing
that skill
so the skill won't be useful if the
consequences are very hard to predict
and we'll assume that the skill is
useful so you are more skillful if the
the consequences of performing that
skill uh are very easy to predict
so this might sound a little um
not
very straightforward why why that is but
let's just run with it and kind of see
what happens if we do that
all right so we want to bake in that
notion of predictability to
help our skills to be a little bit more
useful and in order to do this we will
introduce a slightly different mutual
information so before we are optimizing
mutual information between our task
index for the skill index and
state s
now we'll be introducing a slightly
different mutual information that is a
conditional mutual information and very
quickly just to tell you what
conditional mutual information is this
was the definition of our original
mutual information
now the conditional mutual information
is just we condition everything
on
the conditional variable z for instance
all right
so
the particular mutual information that
we'll be looking at is the conditional
mutual information between the next
state given the current state and the z
given the current state
all right
we can write it out like as this
now what what does this mean so we have
the first entropy term
that is telling us that we want the
entropy of s prime given as to be as
high as possible
and then we have the second entropy term
that tells us that we want s prime given
s and the skill that we are doing to be
as small as possible
so the first term corresponds to
a future that is very hard to predict
for many different skills so if we don't
know what skill you are performing
if your start at the certain state s it
will be very hard to guess which state
you're going to go to next so we don't
know what skill you're performing it's
very tricky to tell what's going to
happen
but as soon as we know what what z is it
should be very predictable it should be
very easy to tell which state you're
going to end up in for a given skill
so this kind of includes that notion of
predictability because we have that s
prime here so it tells us a little bit
about how how predictable is the future
and we can write it out mathematically
and
doing a few approximations for you and
that the result looks um
like this where we have the the
numerator that we're trying to maximize
which is this and we're trying to find
the the log probability of this q phi uh
s prime given s comma z so we want that
log probability to be as high as
possible so given skill we want uh the
future to be predictable
and then in the denominator we would
have uh
something that we're trying to make as
small as possible and that means that
for all the other skills it should be
very hard to predict what s prime is
going to be
all right so what you can see here is
that we have this term
and also this term here that is a
probability of s prime given s comma z
so this is this is something that we
need to learn here
so let's let's think a little bit about
what this is
so this is the term that we are
considering and if you look at this this
actually reminds us of a term that we've
seen before
which looks like this
so this is a very similar looking term
except instead of z we have a's
and this was this term was what we call
the transition model or a dynamics model
that we're trying to learn for example
for model-based reinforcement learning
now the term up here
is very similar except it's not taking
actions as input but it's taking the
skill z as input
all right so this is kind of like a
dynamics model but not for an action but
for an entire skill so it's trying to
tell us given the specific skill what is
the the next state that i'm going to end
up in
and now there is one particular
aspect of this that makes it a little
bit easier which is
our skills our z's itself
are also trying to help this model in a
similar way how we were trying to help
our classifier before now our skills are
optimized to help this model as much as
possible
so skills are optimized specifically to
make the skill dynamics so to
to to
to they're trying to make learning of
this model as easy as possible
so what that means is that hopefully our
skills will avoid situations where it's
very hard to predict what's going to
happen next because you know if you're
just doing random motions it might be
really hard to predict what's going to
happen
and i will focus on some things that are
very easy to predict so that learning of
the skew is as easy as possible and that
would correspond to skills that are a
little bit more useful such as running
forward
all right so summing all of this
together we arrive at an algorithm
called dads
that was
that was introduced by by
archer charmander
and the algorithm works as follows
so we first initialize our policy and we
initialize our previously what we
discussed as a classifier now is the
skill dynamics model q5
now we sample a skill from some prior
distribution and that prior distribution
should be as uniform as possible
in this case i drew it as a gaussian but
it could be just a uniform distribution
we sample those skills
and then we collect m on policy samples
so for given every z we'll give it to a
robot and we'll tell the robot to do
something according to that z
now once we have these trajectories
we can now update our
our skill dynamics model q
given the data right so this is
similarly to learning a dynamic smaller
just in the skill space
and then once we have that model
we can now compute the reward because
that reward is based on that model
okay so we compute the reward
and once we have the uh the reward we
can update the policy uh
given the the the transition the state
transitions that we got and the reward
that we received for them
so and we can do this using any rl
algorithm and i believe that in this
paper the authors use the cc algorithm
to do that
all right and then we do this uh
repeatedly in the loop until it
converges
so we get a policy now that does
different predictable things
for different z's and then we'll do
another set of rollouts and we try to
move towards the direction again
all right so in terms of some results
um so first um if we look at the
trajectories that an ant robot is
producing compared to diversity is all
you mean is so here's a plot that of
trajectories that you get uh if you set
different z's for diversity all you need
or diamond so they're a little bit messy
but they still result in different
behaviors
however if you do it for bats these
trajectories uh are kind of much more
consistent and they go in very different
directions so it's a little bit less
messy
and we can see very similar results on
the humanoid where uh it's just a much
more complicated robot but it's still
kind of very consistent in what
direction it's trying to go and the
skills are a bit more useful because
they're trying to be predictable
all right
so
so far we changed the algorithm a little
bit so that we'll have skills that are
more predictable
so how can we use these learning skills
and uh
as you you've also learned about this a
little bit in the
model based rl lectures where once you
have the model you can
use that model to do model-based
planning so here we can do something
very similar just use skill dynamics for
model-based planning instead
and we can do this using any model-based
planning technique and what that usually
corresponds to is us
sampling different up differences
different trajectories of these then
doing imaginary rollouts using our model
and then seeing what kind of reward we
are getting uh for each one of these
trajectories and then updating our
our planner based on that
so that's really important because what
that allows us to do is that we because
we have that skill dynamics model that
we use for something
something a little bit different but now
this model is very useful to also learn
something at test time where we don't
need any additional rollouts right we
can use just model based planning and
this in the skill dynamics to do
imaginary rollouts and based on this we
can figure out which skills we should
use and how we should compose them such
that we can accomplish a new task
all right but here we are planning for
skills rather than for actions and that
also means that our tasks can be learned
zero shots so we don't need any
additional data
and the address shows some results um
indicating that that's possible so the
result that i showed before of an ant
navigating to different points on that
on that board actually comes from this
paper and it was learned without any
additional data
and the same can be done for a humanoid
as well
all right so to summarize that part
we talked about two different skill
discovery algorithms that use some form
of mutual information
one of them the das algorithm uses
predictability
as a proxy for usefulness of a skill
and then that particular method
optimizes for both predictability of the
skills as well as for diversity and it
allows us to do model based planning in
skill space
and more importantly
the the family of skill discovery
algorithms is actually quite large and
there are different papers that talk
about this um and one exciting part
about this is that not only we can
discover new skills now but we can also
apply it to something like meta
reinforcement learning where it opens up
new avenues so we can potentially do
meta reinforcement learning in a way
that is completely unsupervised where we
first kind of run a skill discovery
algorithm to discover skills that are
useful then we meta train on this and we
kind of keep going
and this is described a little bit more
in this paper by abhishek gupta on
unsupervised metal learning for
reinforcement learning
all right so that summarizes the skill
discovery part of the lecture are there
any questions at this point
there are a few questions in the chat uh
the first question is how do you
optimize q5
how do you optimize q3
right so this is a supervised learning
problem at this point similarly to how
we were training the classifier before
um now q5 q5 is
the skill dynamics model
that is trying to
predict the next state given the current
state and the z
so we have all three of these right we
have the next state from our rollouts we
have the z that we uh that we send to
the robot and we have the state that the
robot was in so we can perform
supervised learning um we can apply
supervised learning to this problem to
learn that model as as well as possible
the next question is
is q of s prime given s comma z similar
to the measure of empowerment but taken
over a horizon with actions induced by z
right yes so there is a very strong
connection between the empowerment and
the measure that was introduced here
except here we are operating in these
rather than in actions and i encourage
you to take a look at the dad's paper uh
in the appendix of the paper there's a
little bit of uh
of motivation behind this and kind of
describe the connection to the
empowerment as well
can you learn skills that are not
locomotion for example for object
manipulations
right so
um
it's a very interesting question so um
usually these skill discovery algorithms
have been shown on things that are
things such as locomotion where it's
relatively easy to come to a
useful skill right so for an ant for
example as soon as you start moving in a
certain direction that produces some
kind of diversity and that skills that
skill is immediately useful because then
you can use it for navigation
with manipulation the problem becomes a
little bit more tricky because for
for us to discover a useful manipulation
skill you probably need to be very
targeted and go to a specific object and
do something with that object and so on
and these tend to be much more difficult
than something like the um the
locomotion scenario so i haven't seen
many examples of these algorithms being
applied to manipulation skills but i
think this is a
great
open avenue for research over future
work
is there a way to reduce similarity of
skills learn movement and rotation
instead of many similar types of
movement that work in slightly different
directions
i see is there a way to reduce
similarity of skills right so
so if you if i just go back in the
slides real quick
uh when we were introducing the
uh the dats algorithm
we were
learning a particular classifier
and that was looking at this uh
right here this log of p of z given s
and this was given the current state
it turns out that you can condition it
on many different things it can be not
only the current state but it could be
the full trajectory for example of all
the states that that skill visited or it
could be just the final state that it
ended up in and
the resulting trajectories diversity of
these trajectories will be a little bit
different right so you would measure
their diversity with respect to the
entire trajectory rather than a single
state
um
and one particular version of this is
introducing this very in this paper
called variational intrinsic control but
uh i guess overall by controlling what
this classifier takes as input you can
control the diversity the resulting
diversity of skills
all right
um
so let me just get back to where
we were
and
i wanted to uh also talk a little bit
about hierarchical reinforcement
learning so so far we talked quite a bit
about how we can
learn skills and then how we can use
these skills by high-level policy but we
don't necessarily need to discover these
skills in order to have this
hierarchical structure where the
high-level policy is able to use some
low-level skills so let's talk about
that so we talked a little bit about why
hierarchical reinforcement are
incomplete might be useful um how it
will allow us to perform the tested
various level abstractions and how it
can be useful for exploration
and
hierarchical reinforcement learning is a
very vast field and
it would be really tricky to kind of
introduce all the different works that
were um
that
that people wrote about hierarchical
reinforcement learning so instead i
wanted to show a few axes on how you can
design a hierarchical reinforcement
learning algorithm and then show you
examples of that and then we'll based on
each example we'll be trying to say what
kind of design choices the the authors
took
all right so
let's build a standard hierarchical
reinforcement learning algorithm
and it looks something like that
so
uh we have a low-level policy pi pi l
and this is a standard policy that we
will learn in
standard flat reinforcement learning as
well it interacts with the environment
it takes a state from it and produces
certain action that goes into the
environment and gets the next state
produces the next action and so on
okay so so far this is just a standard
reinforcement learning
now we'll introduce another policy a
high-level policy pi h
that policy will take the the initial
state
and that policy will command
the low-level policy so in particular it
will send a command z1 in this case
and that command will stay constant for
a certain period of time right so the
level policy is kind of getting its its
goal from the high level policy
and it's the same goal for a number of
time steps
then after the low-level policy is done
we'll take the next state the high-level
policy will receive that state
and then it will do it again but it will
send a different command to the level of
the policy
all right so there are now a lot of
design choices that can be made here
so first
the the commands that the high-level
policy is sending to the low-level
policy can be a goal a goal that is
defined as part of the state space or
not
so
that means that the level of a policy
can be either goal condition
or not so if it's not a goal condition
we can be sending kind of any commands
that then the local policy needs to
learn how to interpret such as you know
maybe a natural language command or some
kind of latent space that the low level
policy initially has no idea about but
over time it can figure it out
or we can send the goal that we want the
policy to reach and this is the goal
that is expressed in terms of the state
space of the policy and if we do that we
can apply things such
such as hindsight experience free
labeling that we that we talked about
before
all right so this is one axis
then the second design choice that you
can make is whether the level of a
policy is pre-trained or whether
everything is learned end-to-end
all right so you can either train the
low-level policy first
and this can be trained without any
knowledge of the high level policy
or you can train all of this given
that's that particular structure all at
once in an end-to-end fashion and then
you will get both the lower position the
high-level
policy right
so then we have the fur design choice
which is whether the low-level policy is
self-terminating or whether it's
commanded at the fixed rate
so in that example that i showed here we
would maintain the command that is being
sent from the high level policy over
three time steps and after this
that's that's kind of it at this point
the low level of a policy
ends and the high level policy gets to
send the next command
but we can also imagine a different
scenario where the level policy keeps
going and it tries to accomplish this
goal
up until it decides that
it's done it can self-terminate
right
and the fourth design choice is that
this is kind of similar and applicable
to a standard reinforcement learning
this can be learned on or off policy
all right so we'll discuss we'll we'll
see a few examples of hierarchical
reinforcement learning algorithms and
i'll go over them fairly quickly i'll
show you some screenshots from the
papers and discuss the results and the
design decisions and then i will ask you
what were the specific design choices
along these axes that the outer stuck
well we'll see if
if you can guess it right
um so
first um let me do this example um
myself so that we can kind of see what
this what this game is about so here we
have our algorithm that we just
discussed this is the dats algorithm
where we discovered the skills and then
we can use them using model-based
planning so in this case the design
choices that the address made where the
level of low-level policy is not goal
condition we were learning that latent
space z that was not a specific goal in
the state space
the low policies were pre-trained we're
particularly using a different algorithm
to learn these skills and then we can
learn another policy on top of it or use
model based planning to do to do
high-level policy
uh the authors were actually performing
them at a fixed rate
so they were not self-terminating
and everything was being learned on
policy we didn't discuss that but that's
uh if you read the paper you will see
that
all right so um let me introduce the
first hierarchical rl work um
which is called uh learning locomotor
controllers this was written by nicholas
hasset at all
and
here's a screenshot from the paper that
shows the structure of their
hierarchical policy
so let's look a little bit closer at
this so first in this blue box we have
the high level controller and this is a
recurrent neural network that maintains
this this uh the state zt
and then we have a low level controller
which is that policy in green here
right that blocking group
now the high level controller is sending
a command called c
to the low level controller and is doing
it every k steps so in that particular
diagram k is equal to two so it's
sending that command here and then the
same command is sent to the next time
step and that's it at this point it ends
and kind of does it again in a second
then we have proprioceptive information
that is given both to the low level and
the high level policy but the high-level
policy has this additional privileged
information
about the task that the low-level policy
doesn't get to see
all right a few more a few more facts
about this paper
both the high-level policy and the
low-level
policy are trained separately they first
train the low level to do a bunch of
different things and then the high level
to operate on this
they're both trained with policy
gradients
and they use what they refer to as
hierarchical noise to the exploration
for the high-level policy or the
high-level policies just sending noise
commands initially
to the pre-trained low-level policy to
the better exploration
and here's a video of showing some some
results
where we have a the snake-like robot
that when when you modulate it with this
high-level noise from high-level policy
kind of does sensible motion
and then if you send noise and it does
something sensible you can learn a
policy
a high level policy on top of it and
here's one example of that policy
navigating to a specific
navigating the snake robot to a specific
location on the board
and then it can also do something a
little bit different such as this kind
and traversal task
and then they show some results showing
how important it is to pre-train and the
low-level policies and uh they
show how much better this algorithm is
compared to the baselines
all right so now the question to you
about the design choices that were taken
that were made in that um
for this algorithm so is it a goal
condition is the low level policy goal
condition or not and please just say one
or two so one would mean it's goal
condition two would mean it's not and
you can just write in the chat
one two one two all right
okay so uh it looks like uh
it can be a little confusing uh so in
this case this is not goal condition so
the high level policy we didn't discuss
it that much in detail so i totally
understand that you might be a little
confused here but the
the high level policy is not sending
goals so just sending some kind of
command c that then the low level
pausing needs to interpret
all right um is the low level policy
pre-trained or they both learned
end-to-end
again write one or two so one is
pre-trained two is e3
one
mostly once there was a
one two
yes they're trained separately so yeah
low-level policies pre-trained
all right next question is it is the low
policy self-terminating or is it
committed at the fixed rate
fixed straight to two there's some ones
yeah okay yeah it's commanded at the
fixed rate we talked about k equal to
two for that specific diagram and as a
train on or off policy again one or two
one one one one okay this is fairly
straightforward yes that will string the
policy gradient on pause all right great
let's jump to another paper
um so this paper is called the option
critical architecture and this is
written by bacon at all
and this introduces a notion so it
actually doesn't introduce it this
concept was known for for quite a long
time but it
applies it to this modern deep
reinforcement learning scenario and it's
a concept of an option so an option uh
here depicted by omega is a triple
uh that consists of this variable i
omega pi omega and beta omega
where i is the initiation set of the
option so it tells us when the option is
allowed to start
pi is a intra option policy so it's a
lower level policy that gets to act for
a uh for a specific
for in that particular state
and then beta is a termination function
so beta is a function that
given a state can tell
the can allow option to tell whether it
should terminate or not right so the
option itself decides when to terminate
and they use this particular diagram
that shows our
standard mdp setting where different
actions led to next states
but then it also shows how this works
with options where at any given state an
option can decide that this is now a
time for this option to go and that
option can make this larger jumps so
this is some low-level policy it doesn't
uh just go to the next state but it can
take a larger jump and do a few actions
to get to the status a little bit
further away and then do this over and
over again and then it also decides when
to terminate
they also show this diagram to show more
or less how this works so we have an
environment that gives you a state then
that state is given
taken by different policies for
different options and then we have an
additional policy over options that then
decides which option gets to go
all right so
um a few other things from this paper so
option is a self-terminating mini policy
they train everything together with a
policy grading algorithm
oh and that's it
all right so to show a few results
um
so
here we uh they they show the uh the
termination
state frequency so they basically try to
depict in which states do the options
terminate and you can see that in this
grid scenario they very often terminate
close to the exit which kind of seems to
make sense so that probably means that
we have an option per room
and then this option get decides to
terminate when it's close to the door
and then they show some results on the
atari benchmark showing that this
hierarchical option critical algorithm
is better than a flat real algorithm
all right so let's do the quiz again so
what are the design choices that the
address made here so first is the low
policy goal condition or not one or two
two yep yep that's not the call
condition are the low level policies
pre-trained or are they trained and
planned
okay
yep they're trained end-to-end great is
the low level policy self-terminating or
fixed rate one or two
one one one yep it's self-terminating
that's what the option is and there's a
train on policy or off policy
the answer is on the slide yes it's on
policy using quality grade all right
let's go over two more algorithms real
quick
um so first let's talk about relay
policy learning this is algorithm
introduced by average gupta
and here we have a diagram that looks
very similar to the diagram that we see
on the right with one distinction which
is that the high level policy is sending
goal states as opposed to some high
level commands to the low level policy
all right in particular the way that the
uh the authors train this algorithm is
by pre-training it with user
demonstrations
and uh they ask the user to do all kinds
of different things in a kitchen
environment uh and these are not tasks
they're just asking the users to kind of
play in that environment and that's it
once they have these demonstrations they
do heavy data relabeling
and they have a goal condition high
level policy as well as goal condition
low level policy
and now you can do hindsight experience
relabeling for both of these levels
using the algorithm that you learned
about previously here
then they do
imitation learning using those
demonstrations those relabeled
demonstrations and then then continue
with reinforcement learning fine-tuning
so a few more facts
these are goal condition policies both
on high level and low level that are
trained with re-labeling
they use demonstrations to print
pre-train everything and everything is
trained using an on policy algorithm
and some results um here is a long
horizon goal
on the left that they want the policy to
achieve and they show how their policy
is uh is pretty good at performing this
task compared to at other baselines and
then they also show results indicating
how useful it is to pre-train it from
demonstrations
all right so again quiz
um design choices is the low policy goal
conditioned or not one or two
one one one yeah great that's gold
condition
is the low level policy pre-trained or
is everything trained entwined now this
is a little tricky
great yeah so there are a few twos but
yeah it's um
it's trained end-to-end
um
so both of them are trained at the same
time it's pre-trained in the sense that
we're using demonstrations first but
it's not that we're training the low
level and the high level policy
separately they're trained at the same
time and that's what we meant by
pre-trained versus
now is it self-terminating or are the
goals come out of the fixed rate we
didn't talk about it explicitly so it
might be a little tricky but
i think your guess one or two
okay we have a few twos we have a few
ones in this case they're being
commanded at the fixed rate that's what
we use for relabeling
and then as a train on policy or our
policy
everybody's saying correctly yes this is
renowned policy
all right so let's introduce the last
reinforcement learning algorithm
called hero
and this is very similar to the
algorithm we saw before and here is a
diagram from the paper
high-level policies sending goals to the
low-level policy they're commanded at
the fixed frequency
um
and the only difference is that this
algorithm
does this hierarchical reinforcement
learning but it does additional
relabeling that allows it to
perform this using off policy
reinforcement learning algorithm so in
particular what it does it changes the
way that the high level policy operates
because when the high level policy
commands a certain goal the low-level
policy will try to achieve it and then
it will achieve a goal that is slightly
different
now when you get that experience you
need to accommodate for the fact that um
the lower policy has changed in the
meantime so you need to perform some
kind of policy correction and that's
when they what they introduce in this
paper
so they work with goal condition
policies with re-labeling
they do off-policy training through our
policy corrections
and then here are a few results so here
is a robot that learns how to push this
block to a goal location and they also
perform in the follow-up paper they
perform
similar tasks on the real robot
and they show how
how their algorithm is able to beat most
of the baselines
all right so the last quiz of today uh
what were the design choices that were
made by the authors so is it the goal
condition or not one or two
yeah that's all goal condition great is
it uh is the low-level policy
pre-trained or is it all trained
end-to-end
yeah a lot of twos yes this is
end-to-end now is the policy
self-terminating or is it being
commanded at the fixed rate one or two
twos
yeah we see
at least one two yeah a few twos yeah
great let's come out of the fixed rate
and um is this an on policy or an off
policy algorithm
two we see a lot of tools yes it's an
off party algorithm and introduces a
policy correction that that allows to do
this
all right great so to summarize um
that part of the lecture
when you do hierarchical reinforcement
learning there are multiple design
choices and multiple frameworks to use
and these are just four particular axes
that i picked that um that we're kind of
iterating over but there are many more
um it usually helps with exploration and
temporally extended tasks
it can be a little tricky to get it to
work to get hierarchical reinforcement
learning to work because now you kind of
the standard flattering first learning
algorithm is difficult to get to work
now you have to do policies at two
different levels which can be quite
tricky
and it also seems like a natural
direction for harder reinforcement
learning problems where you might want
to deal with longer horizons and so on
and in particular if you'd like to get a
little bit more uh
kind of common sense of how these
algorithms work and why they work i
recommend this paper by of your name at
all on why does hierarchy sometimes work
where they show some experiments and
disentangling what what makes it useful
and what doesn't
right so we're out of time so
um
we discussed today information through
the concepts we talked a little bit
about skill discovery algorithms how we
can use these skills and then how we can
apply similar concepts in a hierarchical
url scenario
and next week we'll talk about
agents that can learn
sorry not next week but on wednesday
we'll talk about agents that can learn
continuously over their lifetime
and this is a arguably questions
there's a raised hand from
yep
right i think there are some papers to
try to do more than two levels
i think usually in practice two levels
already pretty hard to get to work given
that the low level is constantly
changing and the high level has to kind
of accommodate for this and because
these algorithms maybe haven't worked as
well as everybody expected at least at
this point people haven't really it's
not a very common thing to do to try
more levels than two
but i think it could be an interesting
idea to our area to explore
thank you
are there any other questions there's a
question from
yes so i have a question so i guess
these kind of two level
systems also have the problem so when
you train end-to-end
there is a problem that is inevitable
phase which is the chicken and egg
problem so the low level depends on
a good high level
agent
and a good
high level agent depends on a good low
level agent so how
is this able to prevent this problem
yeah yeah this is a really good question
um
thanks for for asking yeah so this is a
common failure mode in
many algorithms especially
for algorithms that
make design decisions that make these
problems more apparent for example in
the option framework essence these these
low-level policies um can also learn to
self-terminate a common failure case is
that an option would only act for a for
one time step in which case it's not
really an option
or there will be only one option for the
entire task in which case it's also kind
of doesn't make that much sense because
we want to have this like particular
structure where we can split the task
into a few options but not just have one
task be one option that doesn't really
simplify the problem
um
there are a few design decisions that
made this problem a little bit easier so
for example if you comment agents at the
fixed rate that problem uh
goes away
um
the other one with respect to the
chicken and neck problem that he
discussed is this off policy correction
that tries to kind of think about uh
given a trajectory that the that you've
seen from the or given the goal that you
commanded what would be the
um
the low-level policy that would be able
to
to get to that goal so there are a few
things that you can do to address these
challenges but overall this makes this
problem quite challenging i think you're
you're totally right
thank you
you